Welcome everybody to yet another
FP101x episode. You may have heard
the saying that developers
are people that turn coffee
into code. Well, I'm a developer.
I turn coffee into code and in my
case also
bananas. Here is a
string of coffee cups
but if you look at them like this
this looks like one object. But what
we want
is we don't want to have like one
object we want
to parse this thing into
a sequence of
cups of coffee that we can drink
such that we can code better. So here
you see that I am
taking this thing, that was one thing,
and destructing it
into its true meaning, namely
a whole bunch of coffee cups, that you
can see
right here. And what we are going to
show you in this lecture
how to not parse strings of coffee cups
but we are going to parse strings of
characters
into expressions.
Let's get going. What is a parser?
A parser is a program that
analyses a piece of text to determine
its syntactic structure. So if we start
with
2*3+4 what we want
is we want to have this tree, that says
its two
times three plus four. And again
last time I'll show my string of coffee
cups. Here you see on the left
it is an unstructured thing and then
on the right what we get is the
real structure, namely that it's the
coffee cups
that we are after.
So the thing on the left has no
structure
and the parser is trying to extract this
structure from that string.
One of the nice things
of Haskell and in particular Haskell lists
is that it is quite
nice to write parsers. It is quite elegant.
And it seems that every Haskell programmer
at one point in her career will
write a parser. Let's look at the type
of parsers.
Let's formalize that. Here we
have a function from String
to Trees. That picture that we showed
took a String and turned that into a Tree
so we just defined
a type synonym here: Parser. That is a
function that takes a String
and returns a Tree.
We are going to generalize this type
a little bit to make it easier to
construct the parser. First of all
when we parse a string, we might not
need
the complete string, so there might be
some string left over. Maybe
with our string of coffee cups
after two or three cups of coffee
we might get some heartburn or
we might be a little bit too hyped up.
So there will be some coffee cups left.
The type of parsers, we are going to
refine that a little bit and
we say it will take a String and it
will return a pair of a Tree
and the rest of the String.
What we can also do, in general, is that
when we take a String
it can be parsed in many ways.
There is not a unique way if the
grammar is ambiguous.
Or maybe this String cannot
be parsed into a Tree.
And in that case what we want to
do is we want to return a list
of pairs of Trees and Strings. So
these are all the possible ways
that I can parse this String
into a pair of a Tree and the remainder of
the String.
And that list can be empty in case
there is no parse.
Or if it is ambiguous, it can
contain many pairs. Or if it's
a non-ambiguous grammar, it will either be
a list that has a single element or the
empty list.
By the way, that is another Haskell
idiom. In Haskell
we often use lists, where other
languages would use the Maybe type.
The Maybe type is something that is
either Nothing or a single value
and the list can be 0, 1 or more values.
In Haskell it is very
common to just use lists for both.
And the reason is that you can use
all the list operators quite easily
when you use lists.
But if you are super statically typed
then it is not as precise, but I like
the fact, so I will always typically use
lists. I'm not a big fan
of using the Maybe type. The next
thing is that
really it doesn't matter whether we want
to return a Tree or not
so we are going to parameterize the
type Parser
over a. And a can be a Tree
it can be whatever, we don't care. So the
final type of
Parser takes a String and returns a list
of pairs
of a, that is the value that we are trying
to extract from the String
and the rest of the String that we
don't use.
And in this case, as I mentioned
we are going to keep things really simple
and we are going to
only consider parsers that either
succeed
with a single value or fail
with an empty value. So this list, if the
parse succeeds, will always be a singleton
list.
But we are not going to use the Maybe
type.
If you love the Maybe type, you
can take this
chapter and rewrite everything using
the Maybe type.
But I think what you will discover
is that it's not more elegant than using
lists.
And in fact I think the code with lists
will be more elegant.
In order to build complicated parsers
what we are going to do is
we are going to first create simple
parsers.
And here is the simplest parser that
we can imagine
that will just parse a single character.
So this is a parser that will take a
String
and return a pair of a character
and the rest of the String. If the input
String
is empty
then I cannot extract
a character from that String, so the
only thing I can do is return
the empty list. But if the input is of
the form
x:xs then I can
take the pair of the first character
and the rest of the String and return
the singleton list of the result.
Notice here that we are not using
pattern matching on the left hand
side, so we don't define
item here using two clauses, but we are
using
a lambda expression with a case
expression
that has the pattern matching. So this is
the first time that we have seen
this syntactic construct in use
and also I must say, I like this very
much, because again it conveys
that a parser is a function that takes
the input
and returns a list of pairs. And here you
can also see that it
really returns either a empty list or a
singleton list.
What is another
simple parser that we can imagine?
That is a parser that always fails.
What is the parser that always fails?
For any input it returns the empty list.
And then if we have the parser that
always fails
we also need the parser that always
succeeds.
But if we want the parser that always
succeeds
we need to give it a value
with which it can succeed.
So the parser that always succeeds, takes
a value v
then it takes the input, it doesn't do
anything with the input.
It just returns that value v with the input
unchanged in a singleton list.
And for reasons that we will see later
is that this parser that always
succeeds is called return.
And that has everything to do
with the M word. Ohhh, the M word...
And now my
whole slides got all confused, because I
mentioned the M word.
Be very careful, people, when you mention
the M word
because things will go spooky.
That was the parser that always succeeds.
The parser that always fails.
And now we can look at some more
interesting parsers. How do we take
two parsers and combine the results?
We want to
try this parser and if that
succeeds, we are done
and otherwise we want to try that parser.
How do we define that? Well, we take
these two parsers.
We define a function, a new parser
which is a function that takes the
input. We try to parse the input
using the first parser. If that fails
it will return the empty list, in which
case
we try the second parser on the input.
And if the first parser succeeds
it will succeed with a singleton list of
a value
and the remainder of the input, and we
just
return that same value.
So this thing here first tries parser p.
If it fails, it will try parser q
but if parser p succeeds, it will just
return the result of that. And then
finally here we want to have a function
that takes a Parser
and a String and then applies that Parser
to the String. So here
we get a function from String to
list of a and String. And
it just applies the parser to the
input.
Let's
open up GHC and
check out the behavior of our parsers.
Let's take the simple parser
and try to parse
something from the empty string. That
doesn't work.
Now let's try to parse the first value
from the string "abc". In this case we can
extract the first character from the
string
and what you will see is that it will
return the list
containing a pair of the first value of
the string, the first character
and the rest of the string. This is
just as we defined. So we
verify here that our definition of the
item parser works as expected. Let's try
the parser that always fails.
The parser that always fails, whatever
input we give it
it should fail and should return the empty
list. Let's give it the input "abc"
and yes, boom, it returns the empty list.
Let's try the parser that always succeeds.
And in this case the parser that always
succeeds with the number 1.
We apply that to the string "abc"
and guess what? It succeeds by returning
the value 1
and leaving the input unchanged.
Now let's try to parse an item
and if that fails, we immediately
return 'd'. So we use the parser that
always succeeds.
Let's do this on "abc". Since we can
get the first element of "abc"
that will succeed, so we will just get
the result 'a'
"bc". And now
the last example here
is we try the parser that always
fails. And if it fails
we will try the parser that always
succeeds.
This will fail
this will succeed and it will succeed by
not consuming any input
but just returning 'd' and that is
exactly what
GHCi will verify for us.
The parsing library by the way is
available
from the Haskell home page.
Notice that this parsing is very
simple. There are many many
more advanced parsing libraries out there.
And as I mentioned, the parser type here
that we have shown
is an example of a monad and you noticed
when I mentioned the word
monads
my clicker here went completely berserk.
There is nothing really special
about monads.
It is just a type that has certain
operations on it.
So don't make a big deal of it, because
when you make a big deal of it
you will get into trouble, like I did.
Thanks. Let's take a short break
and see you after the break for part 2
on parsers.